your number-one job is to fill your cup
if you woke up and did the thing that
made you feel both and unstoppable and
powerful and confident every single day
if you started your day with that thing
your life would look dramatically
different one year from today compared
to where you currently are right now and
if you ignore everything else this is
the one where you stop and you pay
attention because this could save years
of your life rise and shine it's an
espresso time what's up believe nation
it's Evan I believe in you and this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so let's start
your day off right together grab your
coffee and sip on today's message fill
your cup over to you Oprah Winfrey also
if you want to know where Oprah has to
say about confidence and excellence
check out my 254 series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the links to join are in
the description below I have paid
attention to my life because I
understand that my life just like your
life is always speaking to you real work
is to figure out where your power base
is they think that success is supposed
to happen like that
[Music]
if I leave you with nothing else it's
just know this for sure there is not one
thing that has ever happened to you
not one experience about one encounter
not one crisis not one joyful thing that
hasn't happened just to make you better
and help you rise every single thing
you're calling in whether you know it or
not when you figure out that you are
calling it in when you actually start
meditating or praying or doing or having
a spiritual practice which is the number
one thing you need if you want to be
successful in the world you need
something that gives back and nourishes
you regardless of what you call that you
need to you need to fill your cup so
that you can be so full your cup runneth
over and you have enough to give to
other people if you don't fill your cup
you end up dried up you end up tired
exhausted and don't have enough to give
it to other people you end up resentful
every time somebody asked you because
your cup is empty and now they want some
of yours so your number one job your
number one job is to fill your cup and
make yourself whole that's your job if
you woke up and did the thing that made
you feel bold and unstoppable and
powerful and confident every single day
if you started your day with that thing
your life would look dramatically
different one year from today compared
to where you currently are right now the
problem is most people wake up like an
accident most people they wake up they
check their phone and they're
immediately responding to other people's
emergencies and demands on your time
you're not in control you haven't
decided to take control of your day that
your day is important that your life is
important and you are going to take
ownership of it and so you need to block
off the time in the morning it may be
five minutes maybe you need 15 maybe you
need an hour and a half whatever it is
the thing that makes you feel bold
unstoppable powerful confident fill your
cup every single day because other
people have demands your time and they
fill your cup for you you have to say
this is my ownership right here nobody's
touching it I'm taking charge now that
looks different for different people how
Oprah does it is different than how I do
it is different than how Dwayne the rock
Johnson does it Dwayne Johnson has to
get his four hours of workout in every
day when he's working on a movie set and
he has to be in by 9:00 he'll woke up at
4:00 in the morning so he can go work
out for four hours and then go back and
shower and get ready for his movie so
he's only sleeping five hours a day when
he's doing movies I think that's crazy
but to him that's balanced that's him
filling his cup that's him reminding
himself of what he's doing he loves
working out that's why I don't look like
towing the rock Johnson right there's a
difference between us I would rather
sleep I would rather do something else
in the morning and so we tend to look at
what we're doing against somebody else
you tend to look at Oprah and say well
she's doing it this way I need to do
that Dwayne's doing it this way I need
to do that
Ivan's doing it this way I need to do
that you judge yourself against other
people's routines and methods of filling
their cup and I think that's actually
recipe for failure because you are not
that person because what works for them
is not gonna be the exact same thing
that works for you here's the good news
you already know what fills your cup you
already know what makes you feel bold
and alive and full of momentum and
confidence you have had that happen to
you in the past
you're just not live in there
consistently you know what has helped
you feel full but you live in there 1%
of the time and 99% of the time you
spend reacting to other people their
demands their emergencies their issues
for your time and so reverse engineer
for yourself when was the last time you
felt filled up motivated confident bold
excited what happened what were you
doing what led to that thing to happen
were you watching a video where you
listen to a podcast we're reading the
book we're going to an event a seminar
were you outside you know I'm sitting
here on a swing here outside where
you're outside you need to get out of
nature do you need to meditate you need
to have a shower do you need to dance to
music like what's the thing without
judgment without caring if anybody else
has to do that thing maybe you need to
wake up every day and pet your frog and
that's the thing that makes you feel
amazing great do that plan for it every
single morning because I guarantee you
if you did the thing that helped fill
your cup then we do feel bold and
unstoppable and confident and powerful
if all you did was wake up every day and
bid that thing your life would be
dramatically different one year from
today compared to where you are right
now you will not recognize your life so
please stop waking up like an accident
and put this into your morning routine
every single day now I've got a really
special bonus kit for you that I think
you're going to enjoy but before that
question of the day I want to know what
do you do to fill your cup leave your
answers in the comments below one thing
I want to make really clear and if you
ignore everything else this is the one
where you stop and you pay attention
because this could save years of your
life the game you're playing is not
success the game you're playing is not
money the game you're playing is brain
chemistry the only thing that matters in
life truly the only thing that matters
in life is what you think about yourself
when you're by yourself and have nothing
but your own thoughts if in that moment
you feel good about who you are who
you're becoming what you're capable of
and what you're willing to do to make a
better future for yourself those you
care about and other people around you
you will love your life it is the single
most pleasurable neurochemical state is
deep fulfillment okay not happiness a
bowl of ice cream brings me a lot of
happiness but it is a very transient
experience deep and lasting fulfillment
matters and what that comes down to is
how you feel about yourself when you're
by yourself you realize along the way or
once you've won something or once you've
made a lot of money it's like if you
don't enjoy the journey that moment is
so fleeting it's gone in a second and if
you don't have the inner mindset of
loving yourself of loving who you are of
loving what you do of of wanting to make
an impact of wanting to help others of
wanting to improve someone else's life
like that it it's honestly
the most empty feeling if you think
that's the only thing and I remember I
had this moment I had worked so
incredibly hard it had been like six
years of competing some people some
people compete and win right away and
they get these covers and you know
that's just what I thought would happen
and six years later I'm still like not
winning not getting covers not nobody's
noticing me and finally actually that
year something shifted for me that the
year that I won like swept everything
and what happened is the year prior to
that I had started training other people
go figure training them for stage really
training them a lot in my studio really
wanting other people to win like making
their wins my win and what happened is
their journey became so much mine and I
became so just immersed in making
someone else's life better that that
next year it was like I was so fulfilled
and happy and that just radiated I knew
that my purpose wasn't just the body I
knew that my purpose was so much bigger
than this one thing that all of a sudden
I showed up on stage is a totally
different person literally people were
like who are you what happened and I had
this moment of I I let go of thinking
this was everything and I actually
learned that the journey is about
helping other people it's about you know
really loving what you do and who you
are but loving the fact that you get to
do what you love for other people and
that just it flipped it literally
flipped on a dime for me and that that
was a moment of wow it's never about the
titles those things are amazing don't
get me wrong I love them I'm not gonna
lie but if you don't do both if you
don't use them or use them as a platform
for something they're gonna be really
empty because they're just a moment if
you want more oprah chuck at the top
fifty rules video i made on her the link
is right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there the way through the
challenge is to get still and ask
yourself what is the next right move